master of none star Lina wait makes
history with her first Emmy win
phenomenally the 33 year old actress is
the first african-american woman to be
nominated and win the award for
outstanding writing for a comedy series
I gotta thank God or else I won't be
standing here I want to thank my mother
for inspiring this story I want me to
share it with the world I love you mom
Thank You Aziz but pushing me to
co-write this bro now we're standing
here I love you forever
ET spoke with Lina on the red carpet
before the big win it's um it's like no
matter what happens it's a win I want to
be a part of the show the love of the
episode has been wonderful man what
about a guy like Aziz what have you
learned just working with him or not
sure you know what to say pay close
attention to what's going on and the
biggest lesson he taught me is don't do
something until you're inspired that's
this thing with us it's like we don't
want to rush the season 3 we never want
to rush a joke we always want to be
fresh and that's where what I learned
from him he's like a mentor to me well
without rushing it what can you tell us
about where the show will go from here
Aziz is refilling we always got a refill
and live a little bit before we go back
in we're so proud of these first to see
them so we want we don't want to give a
half a season 3 so we want to make sure
we're living and enjoying it light so we
got some stories to tell
[Music]
you